Oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un oiseau qui propose avec un nom capello
lettre de et ils n'obtiennent rien
[Musique]
je
et
chante mon coeur et mon contra banier et
machette
[Musique]
et le festi s'engage ponce à entrer dans le
cour de l'empereur de la dynastie
le centre et la capitale
que je ne vais pas l'aimer
les gens
mon rêve
[Musique]
ici
[Applaudissements]
l'est ici n'était pas mieux minimal moi
stretch et frost bar avec piqué gerard
[Musique]
Je ne supporte pas et pour la lumière et la musique je peins
basculer la date de stationnement italienne
[Musique]
temple central et caritas
beaucoup plus de capital
h
deux
ensuite
[Musique]
et
motiver et bari up
[Musique]
et
ici
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]